>>> IN A NEW BOOK, CNN'S
ANDERSON COOPER IS EXPLORING HIS
OWN FAMILY HISTORY AND SHINING A
LIGHT ON ONE OF AMERICA'S MOST
STORIED FAMILIES, THE
VANDERBILTS.
HE WRITES THE UNITED STATES, A
COUNTRY FOUND ON ANTI-ROYALIST
PRINCIPLES WOULD AFTER ITS BURST
INTO EXISTENCE PRODUCE THE
PROGENERAL TERRE OF A FAMILY
THAT WOULD COME TO HOLD ITSELF
UP AS AMERICAN ROYALTY.
BUT THE TITLES AND PALACES TO
PROVE IT.
THEIR EMPIRE WOULD LAST FOR LESS
THAN 100 YEARS BEFORE COLLAPSING
UNDER ITS OWN WEIGHT, DESTROYING
ITSELF WITH ITS OWN PATHOLOGY.
JOINING US NOW IS THE ANCHOR OF
ANDERSON COOPER 360 AND THE
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK, ANDERSON
COOPER.
NICE TO SEE YOU.
THE GUY YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THERE IS CORNELIUS VANDERBILT.
>> MY GREAT, GREAT, GREAT
GRANDFATHER.
>> I LIKE TO CALL HIM THE
COMMODORE.
>> YES.
HE LIKED TO BE KNOWN AS THE
COMMODORE AS WELL, I THINK.
>> HOW AWARE WERE YOU OF ALL OF
THIS GROWING UP?
>> I WASN'T -- I WAS NOT AWARE
AT ALL.
MY MOM ACTUALLY WAS GLORIA
VANDERBILT, BUT HAD A FRACTURED
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FAMILY SHE
WAS BORN INTO.
SHE DIDN'T KNOW HER FATHER.
HE DIED OF ALCOHOLISM WHEN SHE
WAS 15 MONTHS OLD.
AND SHE NEVER REALLY CONNECTED
TO ANY OF THEM.
SO THEY NEVER TOLD ME STORIES
GROWING UP ABOUT HER CHILDHOOD
GROWING UP, SHE NEVER REALLY
SPOKE ABOUT IT.
AND I THINK IF SHE WAS ALIVE TO
READ THIS BOOK, SHE WOULD FIND
IT AS FASCINATING AS I FOUND IT
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T KNOW THE
DETAILS ABOUT ALL THESE PEOPLE
WHO SHE WAS SO CONNECTED TO.
>> SHE WOULD HAVE LEARNED
SOMETHING AND YOU CERTAINLY
LEARNED A LOT.
>> TOTALLY.
I KNEW NOTHING ABOUT -- I WAS A
BIG FAN OF "THE CROWN" SERIES.
THIS IS LIKE "THE CROWN" ON
STEROIDS WITH A WHOLE BUNCH OF
AMERICANS.
IT IS A MULTIGENERATIONAL STORY,
LARGER THAN LIFE CHARACTERS,
SOME ARE IRREDEEMIBLE AND AWFUL.
SOME HAVE EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
BUT FOR ME, IN WRITING THIS,
WITH THE AUTHOR CATHERINE HOWE,
WE WANTED TO LOOK AT THE
COMMODORE AS A BUSINESSMAN, BUT
HOW THESE PEOPLE WERE AS HUMAN
BEINGS, IN THE GLARE OF
SPOTLIGHT AND THE GLARE OF
CELEBRITY AND THE GLARE OF ALL
THIS WEALTH AND HOW THE
PATHOLOGICAL OBSESSION WITH
MONEY THAT THE COMMODORE HAD
INFECTED SUBSEQUENT GENERATIONS.
>> MORE DYSFUNCTIONAL THAN THE
CROWN ALMOST IS PHYSIOLOGICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
>> PATHOLOGICAL OBSESSION WITH
MONEY.
WHAT WENT WRONG BECAUSE YOU DO
FOCUS ON THE FALL.
>> THE COMMODORE HAD WHAT HE
CALLED A MANIA FOR MONEY.
HE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT ANYTHING
ELSE.
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE DAUGHTERS
HE HAD, THEY WOULDN'T INHERIT
THE VANDERBILT NAME.
HE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT HIS SONS.
HE GAVE HIM $100 MILLION WHEN HE
DIED IN 1877 WHICH WAS MORE
MONEY THAN ANYONE HAD EVER SEEN
BEFORE, MORE MONEY THAN IN THE
U.S. TREASURY.
BUT THE SUBSEQUENT GENERATIONS
BASICALLY JUST WENT ON THIS
SPENDING SPREE TO BREAK INTO
SOCIETY, TO BUILD THESE ENORMOUS
PALACES, ALL OF WHICH WERE BUILT
AND TORN DOWN WITHIN A SPAN OF
ABOUT 60 YEARS.
>> WHAT LESSON DO YOU GET FROM
THAT NOW AS YOU'RE WRITING THIS,
AND I WONDER IF THERE WAS A
LESSON FOR YOU IN IT GROWING UP
THROUGH OSMOSIS OR OTHERWISE.
>> THE REASON I DIDN'T KNOW ANY
OF THE VANDERBILTS, I COULD HAVE
READ HISTORY BOOKS ABOUT THEM AS
A KID, I WANTED NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEM.
I LOOKED AS A LITTLE KID AT MY
DAD'S SIDE OF THE FAMILY, WHICH
WAS MISSISSIPPI DURING THE
DEPRESSION AND WHAT LITTLE I
KNEW ABOUT MY MOM'S TORTURED
BACKGROUND AND AS A LITTLE KID,
I WAS, LIKE, I'M STICKING WITH
THE COOPERS.
LIKE, NO GOOD CAN COME OF
IMAGINING A LIFE OF LIVING IN
PALACES AND CONNECTED TO THE
VANDERBILTS.
JUST DIDN'T SEEM LIKE A RECIPE
FOR A GOOD LIFE OR HAPPY LIFE.
AND ALSO, MY PARENTS TOLD ME
EARLY ON, LIKE, PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO THINK YOU HAVE ALL THIS MONEY
WAITING FOR YOU, LIKE, THERE
ISN'T, YOU KNOW, WE'RE DOING
WELL, YOUR COLLEGE WILL BE PAID
FOR, BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO
MAKE YOUR OWN WAY, WHICH I WAS
HAPPY TO KNOW.
I'M GLAD THEY DID THAT.
A LOT OF THE VANDERBILTS SAID,
THE MONEY THEY GOT, IT SUCKED
THE INITIATIVE THEY MIGHT HAVE
HAD AND KIND OF LED TO THIS LIFE
OF ISOLATION AND, YEAH, SADNESS
IN MANY WAYS.
>> TO BE CLEAR, YOU'RE DOING
OKAY, YOU'RE MAKING YOUR OWN
WAY.
>> I'M -- YEAH, BUT I MEAN I WAS
GLAD EARLY ON TO KNOW THAT THAT
IS WHAT, LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE, I
HAVE TO MAKE MY WAY, THERE
WASN'T SOME POT OF GOLD.
>> YOU WORK INCREDIBLY HARD.
I'VE BEEN STRUCK BY HOW HARD YOU
WORK.
NOT ONLY YOUR SHOW, BUT THEN "60
MINUTES," YOU DO ALL THESE
THINGS AND I WONDERED WHETHER
YOU WERE DRIVEN TO DO IT MAYBE
BECAUSE YOU SAW HOW EASILY IT
CAN BE --
>> 100%.
I KNEW MY MOM WHO EVEN MADE
MONEY ON HER OWN, SHE SPENT A
LOT OF MONEY AND AS A LITTLE
KID, I KNEW, LIKE, THIS SHIP IS
SORT OF SINKING AND I GOT TO --
I WANTED STABILITY, I WANTED A
STABLE FOUNDATION.
>> I THINK I'M GETTING A HARD
WRAP HERE.
IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID IN MY EAR?
THAT WAS A HARD WRAP.
WE'LL TAKE THIS OFFLINE.
LISTEN, I KNOW YOU WROTE THIS
LARGELY FOR YOUR SON WYATT,